the family of a 17-year-old shot and
killed by a sheriff's deputy in arkansas
are seeking justice and getting support
from national civil rights activists
hunter britton's family says he was not
armed when sergeant michael davis shot
him
during a traffic stop near bibi last
month
yesterday friends and family gathered to
remember the teenager at his high school
the mourners included the reverend al
sharpton and attorneys
for george floyd's family it's been real
tough
it's uh it's been
two weeks now and
we're finally it's finally it's finally
real jesse britton says his 17-year-old
nephew hunter
should be enjoying his summer ahead of
his senior year of high school
we're still wearing what's going to
happen
with this officer why he's not been
locked up we cannot even begin to
understand this and we need
we need some answers police say hunter
britain was shot and killed during a
traffic stop on june 23
at around 3 a.m his family says he
exited his truck with this bottle of
antifreeze
to place behind his tire to keep the car
from moving
that's allegedly when sergeant michael
davis opened fire
benjamin crump is one attorney
representing the family
the facts are going to tell us
everything that happened
and he should be charged to the greatest
extent of the law
because justice was warranted because
hunter britain life mattered
davis was fired from the sheriff's
department last week
because he violated department policy
when he did not turn his body camera on
until after the shooting here's my
decision lonely county sheriff john
staley released a video explaining the
decision
this means there's no video of the
actual shooting
we see the aftermath but not the
shooting without all the evidence i
cannot
make any determination on whether the
shooting was proper
arkansas state police say their criminal
investigations division
is now looking into the case and whether
or not to charge the former sergeant
with any crime my nephew was murdered
and so i think that he should definitely
be charged with murder
family and friends gathered at britain's
memorial service yesterday
wearing justice for hunter t-shirts
delivering the eulogy reverend al
sharpton called for unity
he does not deserve this people don't
have to qualify for justice
justice ought to be given to everybody
after the funeral
britain's casket was taken out of the
auditorium
and placed in the bed of his own truck
this is above politics i don't care who
you
are who you support all of us want to
see our children
come home at night safe and protected
family members said hunter britain
dreamed of becoming a nascar driver
after graduating from high school
next year you know this is the first
time i think that we've seen
them at a funeral service for someone
that's white and they made a very you
know
interesting and good point that they are
fighting for justice when it comes to
policing
i mean even part of that other sound
bite with al sharpton reverend al
sharpton he said i don't care if you
wear your trump button
or your biden button you should be out
here because it's about
justice regardless of what color you are
and it's just so heartbreaking if you're
the family
all you want is information yeah and
there's no video they have nothing
yeah but nothing brings them back that
heartbreaking scene of
him being taken away in the bed of his
own pickup truck